oftentimes the most difficult part of
accomplishing a project like the Rosa
Parks library museum is finding the
funding to support your efforts this
project has been doubly blessed by
having the support of both Alabama
senators Senator Jeff Sessions and
Senator Richard Shelby they have worked
tirelessly over the last two years to
secure funding for this project and I
cannot adequately thank them for what
they mean to us this project would not
be possible without the full support of
Senator Shelby and Senator sessions and
we are so pleased that Senator sessions
is with us today and as I asked him to
come forward to say a few words would
you please help me thank him for what he
means to us
[Applause]
thank you very much dr. Martindale and
dr. Hawkins and dr. Currie or your
vision it started this out a number of
years ago and all of you at Troy State
University for making this day possible
it's an important program I will try to
be brief
senators are known for filibusters I
won't give you one today but it was a
number of years ago 45 years ago that a
event occurred here of significance it
was not a itty bitty event it was a very
big event in the history of this state
in this nation it raised to the world
and all Alabamians particularly white
Alabamians
a reality that we would prefer to have
not preferred not to think about how
could one defend in the public before
the world a practice that required an
honest hard-working citizen who paid her
bus ticket to go to the back of the bus
simply on account of her car thus on
that day the moral foundations of
segregation were broken and other in
Justices year after year month after
month begin to be eliminated around this
country Rosa Parks is indeed rightly
called the mother of the civil rights
movement I was particularly pleased
therefore last year to sponsor a
Congressional Gold Medal resolution in
the Senate to honor her and to be in the
rotunda of the Capitol when President
Clinton presented her with that August
Medal that given to so few people in
this country and so
[Applause]
it's particularly a also a pleasure to
me with work with Senator Shelby and
other members of this delegation and
secretary Slater who has served very
ably in this administration as the
Cabinet Secretary of Transportation and
I've had occasion to work with him over
the years and become to respect him
greatly and I know he personally cares
about what is occurring here and
supported it truth in so many different
ways Rosa Parks act and the act of those
who worked with her was a catalytic
event and as I said on the floor of the
Senate it was a spark that caused a
nation to stop accepting things as they
had been and focused everyone on the
fundamental issue whether we could
continue as a segregated society after
much courage and effort by so many of
you here the answer to that has been
affirmed no attorney Fred gray who I see
in the crowd was involved in those early
days every aspect of the effort of the
bus boycott and the legal efforts that
occurred afterward he summed that up in
his book bus ride to justice in words
that I do not believe are an
exaggeration in this way little did we
know that we had set in motion a force
that would ripple through Alabama the
south and the nation and even the world
but from the that vantage point of
almost 40 years later there is a direct
correlation between what we started in
Montgomery and what has subsequently
happened in China Eastern Europe South
Africa and even more recently in Russia
while it is inaccurate to say we all sat
down and deliberately planned a movement
they would echo and reverberate around
the world we did work around the clock
planning strategy creating an atmosphere
that gave strength courage faith and
hope to people of all races creeds
colors and religions around the world
and it started
on a bus in Montgomery Alabama with Rosa
Parks on December 1st 1955 Fred I think
that sums it up very well
I am honored to be with you your day god
bless you all
Thank You senator sessions it is now my
honor to introduce the Secretary of the
US Department of Transportation
the Honorable Rodney East later he has
been a strong supporter of our museum
since its inception and we are so
delighted he could be with us today
[Applause]
[Music]
president Martindale Chancellor Hawkins
members of the board of trustees of Troy
State University who could have imagined
on this day forty-five years ago that
something special would begin in a small
and single act of courage that would
give fire and lift to a movement that
would literally change the course of
America and the world and that 45 years
later to the day a governor a senator a
congressman from a distant state and
others from around the country would
gather with mrs. parks and her husband
and her wonderful family and that in
that number would also be mrs. Coretta
Scott King and mrs. Juanita Abernathy
and
Martin Luther King the third and others
who were so much a part of the effort
mrs. Carr and attorney Gray and other
stalwarts of the civil rights movement
there as well dr. Dorothy Height
reverend joseph Lowery mrs. Lawry and
that they would be welcomed by and a new
mayor of that city of where this
historic act had occurred Mayor bright
and that in the number would also be dr.
Mamie till Mobley the mother of Emmett
Till who in that same year would have to
suffer the loss of a son and wonder
about the course of her nation and not
only would they gather but yes as has
been noted renowned artists like Cicely
Tyson and renowned educators like dr.
Walter Leonard they would all gather to
pay tribute to a woman who has come to
symbolize the ability of the human
spirit to use ordinary circumstances to
achieve the extraordinary to give lift
and fire and power to an effort and a
movement again that would transform a
nation and the world here today I your
Secretary of Transportation born in 1955
and pleased to be here on behalf of a
grateful president President Clinton and
a grateful vice president vice president
go on a grateful nation to join with all
of you and saying
- one who turned a seat on a bus into a
symbol of freedom and respect for human
rights who by sitting down caused a
people and a nation to stand up who
caused a young preacher to respond to
the request of Idi Nixon and step
forward and give eloquent voice to her
cause and who caused a nation to come to
realize its need to live out the true
meaning of its Creed yes the legacy of
Rosa Parks it sits there alongside those
who helped to found this great nation of
freedom it is there alongside those who
have used transportation to demonstrate
that it's about more than concrete
asphalt and steel it is there alongside
the spirit of Harriet Tubman who used
the Underground Railroad to take her
people to freedom it is there alongside
the commitment of Homer Plessy who sat
and fought for the right to sit anyplace
on a train it is there alongside the
work of the Freedom Riders who moved
throughout the south to continue to
bring down the walls and build the
bridges and yes it is there in the
spirit of those who walked across the
Edmund Pettus Bridge and traveled along
u.s. 80 from Selma to Montgomery to gain
for all the right to vote it is also
fitting
that the Rosa Parks library and museum
finds its home here president Martindale
on the campus of Troy State University
Montgomery for as the Greek poet and
philosopher Epictetus
wisely said more than 20 centuries ago
only the educated are truly free so let
us then in the spirit of Rosa Parks and
in the words of Galatians let us then
not grow weary in doing good for in due
season we shall surely reap if we do not
lose heart and let us use transportation
as she used it to literally run and not
grow weary to walk and not faint to
literally mount up on wings of eagles
and fly
[Applause]
Thank You secretary Slater for your
wonderful words of encouragement as a
way to introduce you to the mayor of
Montgomery let me say that when you
visit the museum and you will write you
will you will see amazing artifacts that
have been provided to tsum by the city
of Montgomery you should also note that
mayor Bobby bright serves on our museum
advisory board during my very first
visit with Mayor bright after his
election he expressed a strong desire to
be a part of this project and throughout
this year he helped us every time we
needed him it is always my pleasure to
introduce the mayor of the city of
Montgomery the Honorable Bobby bright
[Applause]
thank thank you so much dr. Martindale I
tell you it's a pleasure to be here and
you know as mayor of this great city
this is really really historic occasion
and it really just pricks my heart to
see what we are doing here see the
people look out over the the the
congregation as the preacher would say
and see a meshing of our citizens and
black and white rich and poor young and
old it's it's wonderful that's what
we're that's what the world is all about
and that's what we're all about here
in the city of Montgomery uh you know
it's a historic day to day 45 years ago
tonight or today right here in
Montgomery right across the street a
remarkable lady riding on a bus
beginning remarkable journey a
remarkable journey not only for the city
of Montgomery but for the the entire
nation and the entire world her action
that December day was in its in itself a
simple one but it required uncommon
courage and its effect rippled through
this nation touching the lives of every
single American
she brought great courage and great
change not because she possessed
influence or wealth but because she
possessed courage and character she is a
woman of quiet courage who embraces
dignity and humility each day of her
life and you know as I was trying to
come up with the words that I hate I
could use here today to to really
describe Miss Rosa Parks I think quite
courage was what stands out and it's a
great description of her a great
description of her and her actions and
and those words ring through throughout
this community and I hope throughout the
world great quiet courage for what she
has done you know recently as mayor I
had the opportunity to get a and I'm I'm
mayor one year last week matter of fact
and so I'm awfully new on the job but I
do realize the significance of what
we're doing here I've realized it for
many many years ahead of me becoming
mayor and I'm blessed
awfully blessed to be able to say that I
am the mayor of this great city this
great city where Rosa Parks made the
made the mood she made as so many other
other people here helped start the
movement that we have witnessed
throughout the years recently as mayor I
had the opportunity to get a meaningful
lesson about the movement during the
nineteen fifties here in the city of
Montgomery Alabama soon after taking
office as mayor our police chief passed
on to me a large box of official police
documents that had been put away for all
these years I spent many hours and my
wife bless her she spent many hours also
I won't ever forget one night she went
through these records and she was I was
out doing my mayor duties and came home
late one night about 11 o'clock she was
sitting up in the middle of the bed she
was going through these documents and
she was so excited and her eyes were as
big as saucers and she says Bobby Bobby
come here come here she was so excited
about what she was seeing and witnessing
there in our house in our bedroom with
these documents that were furnished to
me I spent many hours after she brought
it to my attention reviewing them and I
will never forget the emotions I felt
along with my wives emotions as the full
story unfolded in the daily police
reports the interoffice memos the
letters including a letter from dr.
Martin Luther King to the police chief
of the city of Montgomery miss parks is
fingerprints the cards and many other
documents were described among those of
historic documents which described those
historic days here in the city of
Montgomery those items have been turned
over as dr. Martindale said to the tsum
Rosa Parks library music museum and let
me tell you those items brought
emotional moments to me and to my wife
and as I was going through those
documents I realized
we've got so many people not only here
in our city but throughout the nation
that need to experience those same
emotions those same emotions by
reviewing those documents reading those
documents reading that personal letter
from dr. King to our police off in the
city of Montgomery and that letter is
over there with his original signature
and it tells how how he anticipated his
movement and how the movement was a
non-violent movement one for all the
people the nation not just for a segment
of the people of the nation and I made a
determination at that point in time that
these documents these documents have to
be revealed to the public so that they
each and every one who visit the lab of
the museum will see those documents and
read those documents and have the same
emotions and the same feelings that I
experienced so they're there and I
encourage you to go there and read these
documents and get the same feeling this
is a great day for the city of
Montgomery the Rosa Parks Library Museum
will draw visitors from all over the
world we can celebrate our history and
share it with others Montgomery has a
colorful history it has a great history
and this is one of the most outstanding
ways that we can share our history were
the world and with with with the nation
letting them know what happened here
meaning 45 years ago you know the
governor had an opportunity to give miss
parks an award and as mayors of City
Montgomery I have the right to
approximate and I do a lot of
Proclamation but I try to I try to be
very select and any type of Proclamation
that I issue because it can have some
effects here they are negative and I've
experienced both positives and negatives
but I will tonight and I'm announcing it
today I will pro kleh ET tee cember the
first as rosa parks day in the city of
Montgomery and I will be delivering to
[Music]
and I will be delivering that nicely
framed proclamation to her tonight along
with a couple other honorary gifts to
her into a couple of other people at the
gala so I encourage each one of you to
participate not only here today and in
the ribbon-cutting but the other
activities that we've got scheduled
throughout the city not only today but
tomorrow and Sunday in a Monday also
this is a event this is an everyday
event that you can participate in by
coming downtown Montgomery and touring
the museum I want to say one thing and
that is thank you miss parks for your
character for your courage and without
that we wouldn't be here today so thank
you so very much
[Applause]
Thank You mayor bright oftentimes it is
the praise of those who know us best
that means the most
it is our kindred spirits who have held
our hands during the most difficult
times in our lives who best understand
our experiences for this reason we have
invited several very special women of
the civil rights movement to offer their
tributes to mrs. parks now giving their
tributes in alphabetical order of the
following women of the movement
dr. Juanita Abernathy dr. Johnny Makar
dr. Dorothy Height dr. Coretta Scott
King dr. Evelyn Lowry and dr. Mamie till
Mobley dr. Abernathy
Thank You president Martindale governor
Siegelman verbe right senator sessions
honorable rodney slater
and other members of the dais i won't
call any more names for fee I missed
someone it is indeed an honor and a
privilege to have the opportunity to
speak a few words for one of the Giants
of our movement and I want to thank you
as the University for having the courage
to recognize this giant we all know the
story of the Montgomery bus boycott
you've heard it many many times you know
the story of Rosa Parks but let me tell
you she was gentle she is gentle kind
loving sweet de mujer hard-working and a
civic minded individual all of these
things went into play when Rosa Parks
sat down Rosa sitting down and deciding
not to move one more step backwards
cause the nation and the world to move
steps forward her steadfastness her
determination all was a motivating force
to force America to really be America
for all you see back in those days there
was an imaginary line on the buses some
of you are too young to know but the
decision on where one would sit
was left primarily to the bus drivers
and I want to say mayor bright the buses
are fabulous looking today we think they
were decorated for our benefit and they
even look old like the buses did
backfield they've got a Christmas wreath
on the front and they are shining to
perfection
thank you we realized that was not an
accident
but Rosa was sitting in what was called
the black section attire gentle kind
sweet compassionate woman and they're
all from the only seat blacks head on
the bus at that time if White's got on
and filled up the bus was the long seat
across the rear and Rosa decided that
she would not move backward any further
and what I like to think is Rosa threw a
pebble in a great pond that day that
made a ripple effect causing tidal waves
around the world as far away as the
Aborigines in Australia and our brothers
and sisters in South Africa but the
effort of one soul who decided not to
move back any father brought America
forward and I have come today to say
thank you Rosa for City so that we could
be today in Troy State University where
many of us couldn't have even imagined
many years ago of even entering these
doors and Thank You Rosa for bringing us
this far for igniting
candle and the conscience of America
that she should be America for all thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
after all of our people on a diet have
been named I don't think it's proper to
call names but with respect and honor to
all of the persons will only dies today
because they are here because of certain
reasons or whatever I do want to say I'm
glad to see every one of you who are
present here today and to every one of
you who are in the audience today
I want to say to you I'm very happy to
see each of you here today
Rosa Louise McCauley Fox I'm happy to
see you here today we would not have
thought it rose and I when we were
playing together on the school ground at
the Montgomery industrial school back in
1925 26 and 27 that today we would be in
this audience and she would be being
honored for a step that she took in
nineteen and forty five fifty five so
today as we come to this part I just
want to say to Rosa thank you for the
step that you took at the time that you
took it because it was time to somebody
to take a step who would have thought it
that it would have been Rosa that quiet
unassuming sweet little Rosa Parks
god blessed us all Rosa was not so much
physically tired from a day's work as
she was tired and treatment that our
people had gone through and in order for
us to be able to really appreciate the
act that Rosa did we would have to know
something about the suffering the
humiliation and all of the things that
we had gone through and it was just time
God ordained that it was time for
somebody to stand up somebody to do
something and so it was and the person
who Rosa Parks that this came about I'm
happy to say this afternoon that I am
happy that I was a part of knowing Rosa
a long time before this happened but we
had worked together in the n-double-a-cp
and after we had gotten to be growing
when women and gone about our various
ways with our families and things got
back together and we worked in a
community and we saw so many things that
happened that nothing was really down
about it but today we can look around
when we see we have some of our people
who are in the legislature in their
public offices whatever we have somebody
to speak for us and it didn't happen
accidentally it happened because of the
act of Rosa Parks and others who came
together to fight that big ugly - term
segregation and discrimination so today
as we come here and we are thankful to
this institution and to the leadership
here for what they have done this will
be a monument for our people for people
of all the world to come here to see
this and they will know the history of
what happened many times when I speak I
use a word you have to know your history
you will have to know where you came
from in order to be able to appreciate
where you are today and then be able to
voyage forward for what you would like
to see your world to be on tomorrow so
history is
very important and we are happy that
this will be a part of history of
Montgomery so to say to each of you
today
don't let this celebration to stop here
but let it move forward that we will see
better days in the future I have said
many times and this is true go into the
forest and look at the biggest oak trees
you can see
and once that was a little acorn but
today it is a great oak 19 and 45 55
this was a little acorn but today it is
a giant oak and I'm happy to say that I
am a part of it I have been I was there
then and I'm here now so thank you thank
you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
to have the opportunity to pay tribute
is great to do it in the presence of so
many people is so meaningful madam
president mr. Chancellor mr. mayor mr.
secretary my dear mayor its friends in
the movement I'm glad to be here just to
think about the quiet strength the
courage and dignity of Rosa Parks makes
me proud to be an african-american woman
Rosa Parks Lowry F shortly after the
boycott had come to its conclusion and
we all had begun to see new ways that we
could begin to move was in a meeting of
a small group of people and I'll never
forget it because she said so many
people speak about my coming home that
evening and being tired and she said I
wasn't tired that I usually am but she
said I was tired
as of wave we were treated I didn't I
wasn't part of the movement I grew up in
the north but when she described the way
the system worked the fact that even as
mrs. Abernathy has said there was this
imaginal magic line that was there it
always had to be regarded but the fact
that one had to pay the bus driver and
then go off the bus to the back of the
bus and all of that created a humility
that she was tired of
but she didn't stop in a negative way
she went under say to us that she had
been at a worship service at Monteagle
Tennessee in a retreat and she said
everyday there was a person who led the
service and each day the message came
through you are a child of God you could
make a difference and mrs. Parkes said i
sat there on the bus and as a bus driver
began to harass me as he usually did
with others she said it was as if I
could hear a small voice saying to me
Rosa Parks you're a child of God you can
make a difference and she sat down so
that we can stand up with more dignity
and with greater respect that made a
great impact on me and my life because I
came to understand what it means when
one is deeply rooted in faith and
expresses it in a significant way and so
today as I pay tribute on behalf of so
many women I would have words that they
would want to say pay tribute to Rosa
Parks and the millions of women whose
names may never be known who led us to
where we are today I do so humbly and
with gratitude for the opportunity Mary
McLeod Bethune who was the founder of
the National Council of Negro Women
always talked about the importance that
we had of coming together of learning to
work with unity not uniformity but
respecting our differences
and working in unity and I think that I
join with all who thanks thanks to our
senators and to all at Troy State who
will help us institutionalize Rosa Parks
experience in a way that will help us
understand how each of us every day can
and should make a difference and you
remember the dr. King put it this way
when he said we need each other we need
to learn to have to work together and
how to respect each other and he always
said the black man needs the white man
to free him of his fear and the white
man needs the black man to free him of
his guilt if we come together realizing
how much we need each other
if we can act in a spirit of the
nonviolent movement if we can somehow be
stirred by the kind of courage that Rosa
Parks showed we can make a difference
we'll make a difference until we not
only have the freedoms that we have now
the laws that we have now but we will
move on until we have a society in which
there is not only law and order but
equality and justice for all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the president Martindale
senator sessions mayor bright Troy State
Chancellor Jack Hawkins jr. dr. Dorothy
Height miss Johnny car Juanita Abernathy
Mamie till Mobley to all of the
distinguished program participants and
guests in this audience today it's a
great honor and privilege for me to join
you in celebrating the grand opening of
the Rosa Parks Library and Museum
history teaches us that all great
freedom movements began with an
inspiring act of courage and in this
regard the American civil rights
movement provides a supreme example the
library and museum we dedicate today is
a living testament to the courage
commitment and character of the great
woman whose act of courage sparked our
freedom struggle the woman we call mrs.
Rosa Louise Parks and her extraordinary
courage and humility mrs. Rosa Parks
provided our movement with a matchless
example of the very spirit of
non-violence her strength and unshakable
determination her calm deeply felt faith
and pragmatic approach to social justice
all added immeasurable immeasurable
credibility to our nonviolent movement
as my husband Martin Luther King jr.
wrote mrs. parks refusal to cooperate
with racism on that historic day was
based
her personal sense of dignity and
self-respect by the accumulated
indignities of the days gone by and the
boundless aspirations of generations yet
unborn
surely mrs. Rosa Parks was sent to us by
God because few others were so well
prepared to play such a momentous role
in history on that fateful day of days
forty-five years ago just across the
street in the very spot where the
Library and Museum that bears her name
now stands the bus driver picked on one
of the most admired and respected women
of Montgomery in a city full of
extraordinary african-american women the
rhetoric of American democracy finally
had its day of reckoning with God's
justice and the person of Rosa Parks and
by the sheer force of whole will she set
in motion a revolution that continues to
reverberate a nation after nation and
remains an inspiration to human
liberation movements everywhere and now
we have a beautiful place where freedom
and justice loving pilgrims from all
around the world can come and be
educated uplifted and inspired by her
wonderful life and legacy and I must
thank the Montgomery Improvement
Association and Troy State University
Montgomery for providing the tireless
leadership that made this wonderful
facility a reality and so on this 45th
anniversary of her heroic act of
nonviolent resistance we dedicate this
unique library and museum with deepest
respect appreciation and love for one of
the nation's greatest freedom fighters
mrs. Rosa Louise parks we dedicate this
museum and library not so much as a
monument to the past but as an
invaluable resource for students and for
the civil and human rights struggles of
our times and for coming generations we
pledge to honor mrs. Rosa Parks with our
unflagging dedication to use this
library and museum as a resource to help
end racism in spirit and indeed through
non-violence education and action with
this faith and this commitment the dream
will surely become a radiant reality
thank you and god bless you all
[Applause]
to all of our honorable dignitaries our
theyes guests my sisters of the movement
and my friends it is not possible to
think of you mrs. parks without thinking
of your dignity your self-respect your
warmth and that beautiful radiant smile
but most of all I think of your strength
your courage your commitment to justice
and it's been said that still waters run
deep the world will always remember your
quiet yet dynamic refusal to compromise
your dignity on that bus thus setting
off a movement which changed the world
and I want to thank you mrs. parks for
not stopping there for your legacy will
include leading and educating young
people about their heritage and
inspiring them to become future leaders
and citizens through your innovative
Rosa Parks Institute you have provided
the foundation for freedom and
liberation for all of us and we proudly
hail you as the mother icon and Shiro of
the movement for it was after you sat
down that Montgomery could find a young
minister dr. Martin Luther King jr. to
stand up and inspire and walk and
mobilize a movement for justice we love
you and God bless and I must close in
the spirit of mrs. parks and as my
husband says let's turn to each other
and not on each other thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
greetings to each and every one of you I
am certainly I'm full today because not
only am i celebrating in my heart the
contribution that mrs. parks has made to
each and every one of us but I'm
thinking about how things were and how
they are now I'm thinking what could
have been and what is you see when mrs.
Park stood up I'm sorry when she sat
down in reality she was standing up she
was standing for the best in the
American dream
taken the whole nation back to those
great wells of democracy which were dug
but not dug deeply enough by the
founding fathers and those who wrote the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution when she sat down she was
letting all of us know that victory is
not necessarily given to the strong that
the race is not given to the Swift you
see how I crept up here
[Applause]
but you see I've been running a long
time
[Applause]
when the order comes to go all I want to
know yes I'll go I do have to find
somebody to take me but I'm willing to
begin the search just a few days ago
before this call came I fail I was on
the floor 18 hours without help but I
knew I had to get up and finally I
worked out a way this hand was afflicted
with gout I couldn't put any pressure on
it
I had fallen previously and I don't know
what I did to this right shoulder but it
hurts now but I knew that I had some
packing to do and I knew that I had to
get it done and after after 15 hours the
solution came I had to scoot because I
couldn't use my arms and it took a lot
of scooty to get from my bedroom to the
kitchen and when I got to the kitchen oh
I'm home free now but it took me three
hours to go eight feet but I had a
purpose in mind I had something to do
I'm going to have to go somewhere and
God gave me the ability to persevere and
make the journey
you might wonder why we keep telling
this story over and over again
everybody knows the Rosa Parks story but
I dare us to stop telling it if we stop
it's going to be forgotten so I say just
as Rosa kept City somebody started
walking somebody stopped riding
somebody's got up and said we know a
Power greater than this one here on
earth we're willing to suffer so that we
can reign so I'm saying to everyone
today I'm looking in the audience I
can't see too good but I'm a little
worried that I don't see a lot of
children I mean they should be here
if we will take them by the hand and if
we will march them in the way that is
right do you know that we can stop this
drug movement do you know we can't well
I have a time limit but I'm telling you
I could preach a sermon today about our
youth and what but Rosa Parks and please
allow me to call her that because she's
a friend of mine but she has done for
the youth of the various states that she
has worked in and through is something
that these children will never forget I
won't forget her because she slept in my
house and she had to climb over
suitcases and boxes and I said oh no I
needed to call in a demolition squad but
she said that's no problem we'll just
step over this and all we want is the
bed and I am so glad that is my Rosa
Parks left here room and I I want you to
know I kind of got it cleaned up a
little
[Applause]
hoping and praying that another stalwart
soldier will come by and need that bit
it's always ready god bless you all
[Applause]
honorable dignitaries all invited guests
when I received an invitation to this
event
it came with a message from mrs. parks
who said you don't have to do anything I
just want your presence and I thought
not to do anything yet here I am and
grateful to do so I especially want to
thank the officials of Troy University
for providing us and the future was a
museum and library in the name of Rosa
Parks especially for doing it while she
is still here
[Applause]
as I sat listening to the speakers
particularly the sisters of Rosa Parks
I became overwhelmed with emotion and I
know why it isn't possible for me to
speak extemporaneously because I become
too emotional I thought of all the
things that Rosa Parks has gone through
in her life and yet she could say I
didn't insist on sitting down because I
was physically tired I insisted on
sitting down because I was tired of the
way we were being treated well when I
think about myself I laughed myself to
death my life has been one great big
joke a dance this walked a song that
spoke I laugh so hard almost choked when
I think about myself 60 years in these
folks world a child I works for calls me
a girl I say yes ma'am for working safe
too proud to bend too poor to break I
laugh until my stomach aches when I
think about myself I've known rivers
I've known rivers ancient of the world
and older than the flow of human blood
in human veins my soul has grown deep
like the rivers
I'm a the new Fei tease when Dawn's were
young I built my hut near the Congo and
it lulled me to sleep I looked upon the
Nile and raised the pyramids above it
and I heard the singing of the
Mississippi when Abe Lincoln went down
to New Orleans yes I've seen its muddy
bosom turn all golden in the sunset I've
known rivers ancient dusky rivers my
soul has grown deep like the rivers and
so I can tell you about them I have
shaken rivers out of my eyes I have
waded eyelash deep of cross rivers
shaken the water weed out of my head I
have swam for strength pulled by
strength through one Falls with electric
beats I have bought the shacks of water
deep very deep water logs are my bones
I have shaken the water free of my hair
have kneeled on the banks kissed my
ancestors of the dirt whose dirt whose
dark root fingers rose up reached out
grabbed and pulled me rocked me cuffed
me gentle strong and firm carried me
made me swim for strength cross rivers
though I shivered was which was cold and
wanted to sink down and float what I can
tell you about them I have shaken the
rivers out of my eyes and yet sometimes
I feel like I will never stop just gone
forever till one fine morning I'll reach
up and grab me a handful of stars swing
out my long lean leg
and what three hot strikes burning down
the heavens then I'll look over at God
and say how about that
dear Rosa dear dear Rosa
mole friend Jane Pittman always said
[Applause]
people always looking for somebody to
lead them they did it in the depression
thought time and they doing it now
every time a child is born no folks look
in his face and say but you don't wanna
they may not say it like I'm saying it
right now they may not say it out loud
but thinking they do are you the one
well close the box there's no doubt in
my mind that you were the one godness
[Applause]